what's up everyone has it going happy
Thursday another week just breezing on
bias right now how's it going hope
everyone is doing well Persia here we
are chillin today we're gonna be playing
some apex legends because if you didn't
already know we are well underway with
the new events the new bloodhound event
which all the skins and stuff for this
event look very good here's the
Youngblood legendary bloodhound skin
looks pretty cool I like it but yeah
we're just gonna play some apex today
we're gonna be chillin I'm gonna hop
into some duos some poor soul is gonna
be matched up with me and I don't know
let's just chill out have a good time
and shoot some guns you know what I mean
I feel like it's been a while since I've
played I've been playing a ton Animal
Crossing and you know I just I've also
been playing valor in which has been a
huge adjustment and playing and learning
keyboard and mouse and all that
craziness so it actually feels like I
have not touched a controller in a while
but it's all good we're we're just here
to chill and hang out actually I
shouldn't have left the store I wanted
to show you guys the other stuff from
this event so yeah that was the blood
hound skin and also I hope everyone is
having a good day what's good Brandon
and Oscar how's it going dark hunter how
are ya hope everyone's having a good day
safety first the charged rifle legendary
skin it's pretty it's very colorful I
like that the inside of it is purple
like inside the barrel like that cool
more weapon skins epic Ravens watch
I like this color scheme they put it on
life line the skin I do like that color
scheme that blue with that gold I like
it I like it
what's up the boss how's it going
hello crafts dance and work is all I
wanted you
nice name how's it going I respect the
hustle
I respect the interests Wally Khan
what's up I'm doing well how are you
doing I'm just showing off the goods
here all the stuff come included in this
new event that you guys can unlock in
Apex I like this one he kind of looks
like he's like ice-cold his eyes even
let me zoom in his eyes
I like that too you gives me some what's
that Vin Diesel movies and where his
eyes turn that crazy color it gives me
those vibes with that one and lifeline
she always gets amazing skins
she's like the chun-li of this game all
the amazing costumes all the amazing
skins are all great I love them all
please excuse the sirens of the outside
noise you guys already know I work from
home streams you know what it is right
now but anywho yeah I love it love that
blue and gold again be so awesome if I
had points I would get that and I would
get that and we would be rocking out um
there's also some other stuff for some
reason the thumbnails are not loading on
mine right now but yeah this one is
mirages it's so funny because this is
the similar pattern as like life lines
but it doesn't look nearly as slick but
it still matches him it's like a
character I guess so it's just funny how
they're able to do that just with the
combinations of colors and stuff and
then another epic weapon skin gold mine
gremlin are there ago there are little
gremlins on it that is so cool and
they're crawling all over it that is
awesome
dang I kind of want everything let's all
get though let's check out some duos
let's have fun I'm glad I could show off
some of the stuff here but I'm sure you
guys gonna see some action and holy
smokes
I forgot that they did set things up
right now where every hour whatever
it changes the map so it's actually been
a hot minute since I've played on some
Kings Canyon but let's do it let me get
a warm-up game in there before you know
I tried to get someone else in here all
right because it's been a while and I
just want to get a warm up I'm gonna
I'll probably gonna die really fast in
this first one so you know let me get
some warm-ups in let me get the the
hands working again got a got a stretch
stretch the fingers and get the workout
All Right see you later Oscar have a
good one thanks for stopping by anyways
much appreciate it as always but yeah
man Kings Canyon I'm glad that both
mounts are back in rotation oh let's see
can we do this today how how our hands
working today
is the question all right he's going
gibeom
I don't even have the bloodhounds skin
so I'm not on PC I'm playing on ps4 I'm
playing on ps4 I should be playing on PC
because I don't want to ruin all this
hard work I've been fitting in on
Valerie and by learning keyboard but I
also am just like not that good with
keyboard yet so and I I do I have been
playing apex on PC with my controller
though but for today we're chilling out
Plus this is the only way I can play and
still possibly talk to the team e I like
going over there and trios so let's see
how this goes
so my gosh just gonna be him that's all
good I actually miss playing apex I've
been playing so much other games there's
too many things to play you know too
many things if you have a respiratory
system I almost forgot I was done master
but it's all good
like there's definitely people here I'm
already bugging out hold on hold on okay
we ready I need that he found a gold
shield oh yeah let's go TV let's go all
right this is gonna be good
teammates gonna carry it's gonna be
fantastic
watch out for the new kill leader friend
I don't know wait where's my yeah level
three I don't want to open the door oh
yeah there is something here okay okay
okay okay I don't want to give away our
position where is he Oh Julie
see you late I have a good amount I need
heavy animals what I need over there oh
there's double tap this of course is a
double - oh wait did he go here
I feel forget walking doesn't hide my
footsteps God be careful
gotta be smooth push my teammate alright
he's above me
hmm some death boxes over here let's
explore it this way oh yeah oh my god
yeah let's go d me yeah
oh no never
[Laughter]
[Music]
sure
oh my gosh I've forgotten how to do
everything what the heck is crazy
oh yeah Persia Mike Cenci
I know we need to reunite the squad no
I'm not gonna use it right there I'm
definitely out of heels though
attention she's gonna keep it moving and
guys we're still alive right now so
that's kind of lit man Kings Canyon
though I feel like it's been a while
although I did grow to love world's edge
whoa if someone down over here yeah add
something else yeah whatever you had
homie already took it that's all good
we have heels seals syringe oh man I
forgot ah I forgot everything is the
grenades oh my God my looting lurid
saved me please have mercy on my soul's
thank goodness there's no one's sniping
right there because that's what I'm
always terrified of when I play with
controller on PCs like I never want to
leave I'm like oh my gosh is such a bad
idea Bailey did right now my old homie
my teammates good so and there's ten
squads left what's this blue one was it
just a different color helping
horribly out of out of touch with apex
lately thanks
oh sorry guys my bet
damaged myself like a tart tart I'm
gonna humming I will be less poop
eternity right now about except the
totem oh I forgot they super buffed him
they super buffed him
oh no oh tartar sauce back up real quick
oh man he has that he has that red thing
I guess we don't technically have to go
that way we can make smart plays you can
make smart place we can make smart plays
Louis come with me if you want to do Wow
we got this six squats I just have to
not have brainfart moments like most
times
definitely wouldn't hurt to get more
there's someone here
oh it was a wraith now she knows she
knows we know she knows we know she
knows we know they see us okay they
breath they ran yep they're inside
they're looking for me oh my god no I
choked it I chose it it's fine that was
the warm-up game that was the warm-up
game we almost had it
that wasn't bad we got we got for it
that was actually a lot less funnier
than I thought it was gonna be I thought
was gonna be like five teens stacked up
on top of each other but we good we good
what control am i use them even ps4
controller I have been playing Lauren
actually I have been I've just still
been kinda getting used to a mouse and
keyboard so it's kind of been a little
bit more of a grind with Laura but I've
been having fun with that been playing
last few days when I'm not totally
absorbed by Animal Crossing of corn oh
yeah I gotta find out where on the map
the town takeover is actually yeah not a
bad not a bad warmup
Landon okay but you were talking to me
12 minutes left of Kings Canyon oh snap
I felt like I could have got that guy I
should have realized I actually did get
the reload off on my are 301 let's all
get songket oh yeah let's go team robot
team robot let's go
I got my key through through work
through here good old GameSpot welcome
welcome but yeah but if you guys heard
about the news every person much dreams
will orient now gets a key drop so there
are more chances for you to get it and a
good way to support small streamers so
yeah I'm going to give him that he seems
like he knows where he wants to go and
I'm gonna try to say what's up since
chat before the the game gets tight it's
hard to read chat and respond the jet
when I'm also trying to not suck which
is really hard in this game how's my
coin since I'm a crime scene is going it
is going being able to like hang out
with everybody like online and like play
games like this does help the cabin
fever a bit but you know it's gone and I
hope everybody else's quarantine is
going well hope you guys are doing well
right now oh we've got company oh oh my
gosh
oh oh yeah I missed the crap out of that
[Music]
pleased with it no she chased me all the
way over here of course she didn't
all right now I can talk to you guys and
hopefully my teammate cannot can help me
back nice job schemas ham sometimes but
yeah there's a lot of damage done listen
every stuck inside
nice we're close to a beacon we'll be
back in this game in no time
yeah I took my friend like a week to get
a drop which was really crazy and she
had like a bunch of streams on top of
their purple shield yeah this guy my
teammate was really good I just didn't
find a gun and it didn't help that I
with my grapple didn't help me get away
my bet she made my bad it's okay there's
still time for me to get a couple more
kings canyons magic I mean if I have a
good game just time for one more but All
Right see you later madhouse have a good
one thanks for tuning in
you're a 245 level on this nice I know I
haven't activated like you know my true
power is it oh no he's taking Pathfinder
ok who else do I even play you know what
let's play boy down this is why Donovan
right why not we have to time to get
good time to try my best
it feels so weird coming back to the
controller actually after playing on
keyboards like the last week or so now
I'm playing on ps4 right now
Oh or I was playing on ps4 whoops okay
[Music]
got it
let's try that one again shall we yes
I'm playing on ps4 although I have been
playing on PC Apex recently but I'm also
using a controller when I do play on PC
apex sometimes I feel like it's a lot
easier which might sound weird but but
yeah well
just try that again it's almost the end
of the Wow oh no I was like they
switched it Rio's already but you can
pick both you can pick both don't forget
you guys you have options now
lifeline is a must in duos all right
cool so somebody picks pasyami right
I'll take I'll be lifeline lifeline was
my first main although when I started
playing Pathfinder a lot I kept
accidentally throwing my bot out on
accident when I'm trying to like grapple
around something oh my goodness my
teammate has a mic I mean I could tax
him but you know I don't want them to
make fun of me so so I don't now you're
good bin
I mean that happens all the time in apex
actually at least for me I could just be
unlucky
Oh master FX is like westling so I'll
give this game jump hours cuz I felt
like he would have left without me but
oh boy
spiced um I don't like going here
just cuz I need time to set up my RNG
isn't always that great Mike there's
already a hundred people here oh I
forgot where the door was oh oh my god
my aim my aim
okay kill this teammate nice Oh someone
else killed to see me I need to oh my
god did I really use on Miami and
missing all the shots no oh okay
that's fine you scared the crap out of
me actually did not know he is it
so they again
um big fan GameSpot awesome wish you
would join but you're playing on PC
maybe next time or or maybe I could
always just send in a brain l2 but that
would take time away from the stream
time but the next time I get I play apex
on stream I'll play on PC cuz I can so
use controller on PC which is fine oh my
goodness I panic so hard so funny I've
been going through a rollercoaster
I've been going through a rollercoaster
of of FPS games lately and like played
some zoom eternal a nightmare mode which
is like insane and then playing a lot of
Valor ant which is super slow pace and
then trying to come back to this I'm
like man I've been having to adjust
everything I've been working on every
time I play a different game fine with a
challenging I think there's a chance
they reveal a new marvel at you bow
during Marvel - ah guys you already know
me and you Wow that dinosaur has a gold
box in advance you guys know me I've
spent many years getting let down by
Marvel rumors so I just don't get my
hopes up for that stuff anymore I just
hope and pray that it might happen and
if it does dope
and if it doesn't and I didn't have my
my hopes up for I just wait and see it
happens of course I would want that to
happen that would be really cool but
there's action oh man you got a purple
shield I didn't even pick up a shield
yet why did I shoot at this guy caddying
I need a shield badly oh yes no no no I
me oh man I just got it I just got the
shield it's not fair
crap well let's see how Tarzan does okay
we didn't have to wait
dang I told you guys my RNG is not good
I got it I gotta land in the hotter
spots that sort of did 53 seconds to get
a duos match before they switch the maps
to world's edge do I prefer world's edge
or king's canyon when I first are
playing on world's edge I was like man I
miss Kings Canyon and then when they
brought it back for the first time I for
a really long time I realized I think I
might like world's edge a little more
now but it depends this guy already
salty good start yet
I was like yeah always on a roller
coaster with all types yeah seriously
it's like there's a lot of games out
like FPS games out and they're all
different like ones that are coming out
right now or are really popular right
now and they're all different which is
cool but also hard to be good at them
all for me at least it takes me a long
time to be good at the corn I have been
jumpmaster everything oak let's see I'm
just gonna relinquish I'm gonna let you
do it
least likely that the only rage quit on
me if I let them drop man everyone loves
going over there look at this look at
this mad house we're gonna have over
here
okay this fat mini I don't think
oh no I missed it oh no I'm bad and I'm
also so so that's my teammate or Oh
[Music]
oh my goodness and we want to get our
teammates so let's get out of here he
wants you to resume but it's so it's
spicy over here dude oh my gosh I hear
somebody
I'm just gonna try to keep it moving oh
my gosh she's so many people here there
are so many people here don't mind me
you guys
nothing's going on here crap get me
inside this guy wants me to revive em
Darius great okay they're distracted
this is our chance
okay okay see you know what they're
they're distracted we're fine no one is
gonna do a thing to us we're good all
right let's got here hey team and we
want to get out of here there's a bling
hmm that's a far ring mm-hmm oh that is
so funny oh no it shields the cape dude
I'll watch your back all right he's here
I'll be back honey because he's gonna
need a gun I don't think this image yes
because big batteries uh man I've
totally forgotten like honey's all my
stuff wowsers yo Richie please save me
in the chat my bro
thank you homie
to make sure they were in Russia not
here to get me oh my gosh I've forgotten
how to do everything here
no no make it
medkit here hey where is he going
recharging I got 13 heavy bullets and a
prayer all right
no placing a portal mic I set the portal
no I didn't know what a big bet it I'm
hurting for resources right now okay
I'll take that to you
ah let's see I don't know man I don't
know where this swing went oh okay
they're over here but my teammate we
could just get him I better shield
there's a 13 squad still like this game
has been going on for a while
they're definitely over there oh I saw a
portal um we are running away from this
ring which is not great now we have to
fight against the circle and because
this guy wanted to go way over there
should I just test my luck
oh boy oh boy yeah this is bad yeah oh
my gosh see that's how you don't want to
play it you guys that's how you don't
want to play it let me be an example of
what not to do in apex I knew we were
running away from the ring and I still
condoned the behavior so that's on me
[Laughter]
yeah nice try dude I think it's back to
world's edge now oh snap
I should have known I shouldn't know it
was my own fault I called it out - it's
like we're running away from the ring
like very not smart people yeah that's
all good it's all good
oh yeah I still haven't watched it which
is a shame like I seen the trailers but
not the full thing back to world's edge
it's crazy how realistically I feel like
I've only not played this game for like
maybe a week or two but it feels like I
haven't been playing for months
it's like how do I drop stuff out of me
and been sorry again what do i do I
haven't been making good use of my hats
minder either
introducing your champion team dodo code
that's what my new a vaccine is gonna be
Animal Crossing
I like going here but it might be
different in duos
so remember it's like less people on
your team so less health and possibly
just like more teams in one area
let's pray for the best I feel like no
one drop behind me so that's good news
wonderful hello there's someone guys
come in here attacked with hospital I
don't have a shield oh so oh no cause he
had a shield oh my god the other way I
did that white shield was like in sight
it was like the carrot hanging from a
string dang alright it just being like
that doctor fruit who are my favorite
characters to play as Pathfinder
Octane's fun
just cuz they're like quick and I like
being a little bit faster you use a P
2020 you really want me to lose I
remember not too long ago I was in like
the firing range with some friends and
we're having like P twenty20 battles and
stuff and it was it was super fun but
I'm trash with that gun I personally
liked are you 45 even over a few other
weapons too
dang it went down like that that's the
only thing about do students it's like
easier to wipe squads so it's a little
faster I think but I don't know
sometimes I feel like it's pretty slow
like slow pace like that first match I
played on stream it wasn't that spicy we
ran into like one team and then one team
and then one to you dogs depends on
where you go oh my lord oh this is this
is where it is ooooh I kind of want to
go in their next game or if we survive
this
um teammates going in there I'm gonna go
upstairs I don't know why I engage when
I have literally no shields we ain't
scared you oh yeah
I'm just a distraction oh oh just
kidding
I have no shields bro oh I missed I
should have hit fired I'm Barry with the
hemlock hip fire them idiots
oh man dropping too early is spicy
extra extra spice that's like eighth
wing on hot wings spice right there
what's good Brandon business how's it
going guys you don't want to suffer with
me on your team trust trust
revenant oh yeah I should try revving
and also with his buff that ball got
bust he got buffed
let's try one out with him
I'll see our teammate wanted to be
Pathfinder anyways we got it we got to
share the wool hip-fire yeah exactly I'm
like oh man he's talking I didn't hear
what he said but especially if I don't
have like a site on the hemlock oh dang
I definitely need to hit fire it I can't
really see well through that tiny iron
sight alright
I believe in ours in our squad right now
team robot team dodo BOTS oh he's
talking to me but I can't really hear
him oh okay I did some damage oh my gosh
there's nothing kids oh I forgot I
forgot I'm not that binder okay crap
yeah there was so many people in there
oh I know I know I know they're there I
need a weapon though I literally have
nothing okay we have weapons now no
shields but we have weapons crap I wish
it was at least a white shield up there
oh my gosh maybe here is Jimmy here okay
thank you
yeah we don't have to entertain this
are these blue ones special thing I kind
of don't want that I'm really bad with
the Scout almost really bad the wingman
but some ammo for it so I'm on my way
hold up hold up there's two blue shields
yeah all right I mean I didn't do much
there but we lived so be proud of that
[Music]
I don't want this but we're gonna take
it anyways once I get a select-fire then
I'll keep it oh I have the totem we live
we live do you guys write it on my
tombstone out of shadi Hamilton
my hero
Wow this this like skin is crazy-looking
got it got it dude you got it hear you
loud and clear let me just open these
okay yeah I get it
I hear you oh I hear you but you're also
not down here with me and so I first
expecting me to chase him I'm not
well-liked they took the balloon
oh my gosh
oh my goodness
for a split second I forgot it was a
brace fire hey yeah yeah yeah it's fine
it's fine fine we live for a little
while we live longer than the last two
matches show my stats oh my gosh my
stats are not good oh he's so creepy
they just psyched me out I thought I got
something gold for a second I don't even
know how to look at my stats which is
also weird I usually use Pathfinder
let's see yeah I don't even know how to
look at my stats let's let's go again
oh my goodness I'm just you just
reminding me back when these girls
talking about like being in clans and
stuff I remember way back in the day
when I was like playing Halo 2 and
everyone had their clans throw back good
times good times
there's the stream delay there's a
stream delay from the chat and and what
goes live just a little bit it's not too
long but there's a little bit of a delay
so bear with me you guys hmm
revenant was cool though I haven't used
them much because cool oh yeah you like
my Pathfinder skin heck yeah what else
do I play oh man it's like that's a
question that's hard to answer they're
just like too many things but as of this
past week the most stipend plays valoran
and Animal Crossing so so yeah a little
bit of a different different pace
oh yeah thank you because I almost
forgot I really wanted to go over here
to check out the new area the town take
over actually I've never landed over
here so I definitely want to check it
out by gonna be a million people no
nobody
wait there's nothing but ammo here
where's the crap I just picked up
anything I could find okay it's the only
way you back up there through lose it by
my teammates doing all the work I swear
I'm coming to help this area's cool
looking though thing you know stylo
tearing it up yeah now we can check out
the area
oh you can close the door
oh yeah oh crap
oh no I trade the nice with the wrong
[Music]
guy to some monsters I forgot that this
had this whole part in here like that I
don't even have anything with that guy
right that was fun even though I
definitely almost got destroyed cool
that was the first time I ever did that
actually my first time seeing it in
action like I had seen the trailers and
I kind of saw some screenshots I think
before people showing the actual dogs on
the floor it dead so that was cool that
was kind of fun didn't know what to
expect but it was great
ROM - oh wait hold up homie I was not
ready for that
Oh a man I've been so out of touch with
Apex and they do all this cool stuff
like this and we're like outside the
Rings whatever we got this oh and dad oh
yeah oh crap I'm not I'm not
man I see me almost didn't make it out
of that where's that is this it oh it's
a gold shield here you take it
let me get that yeah thank you
I didn't well exciting when will
Pathfinder get his cinematic yeah I
wanna see a pathfinder cinematic that
was IDO thanks I'm gonna need it
that was fun I'm not gonna lie I'm
actually surprised more people didn't
come this way for it but let the game
before that we saw like a ton of people
were over here so we just got super
lucky all right so let's get out of here
I guess
[Music]
yeah what do they do
what did I do ah okay I remember I'm
revenant I still hear the little robo
feet so oh man we gotta go bro
you've gotta go bro
[Music]
the ring is far no boy I guess we can
take the balloon all of that to die to
like the ring please no oh my gosh I'm
seeing all these weeds and I just want
to welcome too much animal crossing
there's a tower over there
oh my gosh let me up let me up hmm oh oh
there's people fighting over there know
what you wanna fight him all right Oh yo
yo I took ten million years to set that
up and I have nothing long green be
there so I hope this
I hope Nino's got us I think he does
have something longer
oh I did not get the one that I wanted
it's the corner tippity tip corner of
this building in the ring Oh
no oh [ __ ] I revealed him
no that was unfortunate no I was gonna
like run into the corner and use my
death totem but it was so close it was
so close I usually don't use all-star
but in close-range situations like that
it is pretty good so I had everything I
needed to win that game I just couldn't
do it
just get it do it it's all good thanks
for hanging out with us and good night
arcturus have a good one
all right I haven't been making good use
of revenants new stuff gotta remember
use the abilities use the abilities and
Crouch more I can Crouch more cuz they
took a low profile off of him which i
think is good because now his fast walk
is more useful a doesn't take as much
damage so yeah if it still works like
that alright we're going here again my
friends
oh man okay I'm only gonna go over here
because I saw a lot of people drop and
oh yeah they're really close huh oh my
god so many people over here what a
mistake I shouldn't have changed my game
plan oh and there's people sniping at me
make them work for it you can't get me
ow okay you got me once but it's fun
because I'm gonna find poop some stuff
here that's for sure
I promise you I'm gonna find it don't
know if he's still alive somehow nope
how do I live so long and there's such
unfortunate circumstances yeah but I
have stuff to survive I can't live every
just that dodging we've octane is by far
your favorite I think it's super cool
I think he's super cool like from
character design to his abilities he
like his backstory I dig it I dig it and
running fast is always great playing
Animal Crossing while watching heck yeah
heck yeah I loved that game too much I
loved it too much actually
I was trying to - trying my best to
dodge and weave every bullet yes I
wasn't the first squad I'll let's go I
will take that with me you know what I
was too scared I was too scared I should
have just went in there I should just
threw my abilities that's what we're
doing right now that is what we're doing
running it back how are you doing Jordan
by the way I miss everyone so much
I'm playing on ps4 right now but we
should play together soon you know what
I'll chest and I teammates and take this
somewhere
although I'm I am glad we got to do that
little gum he gave it back to me
all right fine all right fine
darn the places I would usually drop
we've already passed so let's go to
Mirage boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel like there are so many other cool
places on the map that people won't be
going to the Mirage boyars anymore this
could be free loot maybe a free ball key
you never know oh there's definitely
people here oh my gosh
urban Josh oh man one bullet No okay I
hit him with my thing with him I lived
with nothing oh I can't even go into
that building okay well thank you yes
I'm sorry I did him I'm on my way
Hey oh man 16 bullets crap oh and then
he disconnected all right so we keep it
moving there's no one left to save we
shall continue on I was gonna go up
there with my 16 bullets all right don't
think I'm not crazy
cuz I am look at these guys crazy this
game drives me crazy that's it that's
that's the real truth but they can have
it they can have the boat
oh yes please thank you don't think I
see anybody just minding my own business
hmm
double light guns let's go no other ammo
needed darn now I kind of wish I picked
pathway instead better talk way out here
what action up there someone kind of
left out
oh there is it
[Music]
I'm in the fire and I don't want to be
in the fire I can take him
he was reviving his Chi me
whoo okay let's go read that wasn't the
guy though oh I can't I can't pick it up
until I oh crap what do we got in here
while I'm shopping
oh there's such good things okay unless
there's a way to manually turn it off I
gotta be fast why do I need a knockdown
shield no one's gotten arrest me
we need Miami folks you need more ammo
folks
I know they're coming from behind me
because they spawn there must a went
through the cave yeah let's run through
my least favorite part of the whole map
it sounds like a plan
you can't see me Oh
booted yeah my teammate is gone you guys
he's gone late Emma oh yeah oh yeah
thank you
I'll rummage through the scraps heck
yeah
are they in there sounds very cranky we
could just sneakily saw that slice
smooth that's smooth feet
we're in the ring so I don't really have
to be too crazy right now
but I do think they're on the hunt how'd
the hunt
slowly I see in my feelings okay maybe
I'll pick up the strap I'll take
give me that ammo though oh there's
other people waiting nice
yeah my gosh just spectate who have made
- go to them again
hold us let's see alright we're not in a
bad spot we just need to find
better place to post up we're gonna get
top ten aha
top ten when I tell you I tell ya
anyone's gone this way alright sniper
now alright what's up guys how's it
going
I had a I had a purple mag for my car
buying my R 301 excuse me someone gave
me flak for killing at a carbine even
though technically I'm not wrong
Zoro will place the weight
the rain is moving in though
it's bound to be somebody to come from
that direction
I'm in the trees oh no the Train I was
not coming inside
Oh No why do I have so many grenades
he's talking about me or is he talking
about the other theme because no I don't
want I don't want to draw them close I
want to sneak up on them when they're
fighting you know the the good ol third
party or in my case uninvited guests
since that's only one oh that sounds a
lot further than I think it is don't
know if there's anyone still here
this could be such a bad idea I'm almost
certain it's about a bi yep there they
are there they are oh do you think he
saw me and I don't know I should've
waited in the train yard it's fine it's
fine I didn't have much hope in that
anyways we got that one guy earlier we
had to kilts not that for being so now
that was cool down
I definitely think he's more valuable
now as a character than he was before
revenant thank you I very much do you
enjoy my coffee table as well ran up on
someone there you go that was that was
as much as I could run up on two people
as I could
my least favorite character um my least
favorite character to use is probably me
like at the squad I don't know maybe
crypto only cuz like I feel like he's
really hard to use and he had to have
like a good squad with you and all that
jazz but not because I think he's a bad
character I think he has one of the
coolest actual designs so I really like
him and the guy who voice acts for him
actually plays apex and he's super cool
so I think her character super cool but
he's probably least favorite to play
because
I'm really bad at using the drone
effectively and I guess I flied to
predictably with my drone cuz I always
get shot down so yeah what's up black
olive how's it going hey ash
welcome all right here I knew you
dropped this somewhere I'm the
jumpmaster that was still super fun the
little arena he gave it back to me
alright still my favorite place to land
it's just probably spicier now than it
used to be even though there was only
like six of us left
how much money do I spend on skins I
spend no actual money I spend my in-game
currency if I can afford it
girl needs a shield though or the shield
acts like fire oh my gosh you know what
no more messing around I'm going to go
find a shield shield there's no shield
over here this is absolute shenanigans
it's usually always crap we both don't
have a shield we gotta go I ran right
through him did they change that oh no
I'm gonna die dry now view
hey guys she's so lucky she's so lucky
the gold shield I'd know his shields
that was insane
alright you keep 469 damage like all of
that was on the same purse
oh my goodness
there was no shields on that side of the
of the room
why how is it possible my orangey is
that bad
how not even a white shield this is why
I don't play the lottery you guys this
is the exact lottery
see you later Brandon thanks for
stopping by what's good doom Slayer
welcome back play kostik oh my goodness
kostik is super fun actually I played
him a lot during winter express she got
it oh my gosh I don't even have a
teammate
it's fine and I'll need a teammate I'm
my own teammate I am my own teammates
[Laughter]
sorry s guard I'm not expecting a match
right now plus we only got a few minutes
left of the stream so I would hate just
to get you into one mansion like have to
get off right afterwards but soon soon
soon soon soon we'll have like a little
community D maybe if one of the days
where like Ben and John Luke Ryan
available you can make it happen
plus I've been so rusty I have not been
playing apex much and I'd be a horrible
to me you don't want me to be on your
team right now oh my goodness so close
to getting that Watson she definitely
healed up
oh boy Mozambique no I thought somebody
landed on the other side of me I'm gonna
stay quiet I hear my gosh yes I needed
that last yeah I was hoping they would
have been like me last game and not have
found the shield and maybe I could have
taken that guy down real quick
but nah didn't work out didn't quite
work out you know what for the last game
I'm gonna play trios yeah a little extra
help and it's on world's edge so last
game last game in the stream let's get
some extra help so at least if one
person dodges I'll at least have one
teammate so in theory in theory we could
all just get totally wiped out right now
and then that'd be the end of it that's
just how it goes sometimes in the world
of apex legends
all right you bad guy is going
pathfinder oh he's going baletta
actually I kind of went to use revenant
for the last one who's been pretty cool
so far
yes we got this I have some extra help
now
oh I got a Gibby and a bloodhound all
the protection and all the vision and
then I'm just gonna shut everyone down
that that's the goal that's what we're
gonna do
dang guy had a lot of kills
this could be really dangerous so I'm
gonna try to stay kind and close to the
team oh my gosh Oh spitfire time close
the door close it you can let in the
drafts no I'm so bad no I was like I'm
gonna land closer to the team oh I was
off by like literally nine damage I
cursed us
I actually cursed us I was like we could
all just get wiped out right now alright
that's not gonna be a last match Oh
feels bad damn you Spitfire
I couldn't imagine firing that gun in
real life I feel like my arm would just
fall off of my body and land on the
ground
alright last last last one right here
we can't go out like that can't go out
like a chump
All Right see you later cyborgs have a
good day have good class
thanks for hanging out I know right now
it was to Bucky it was just to Bucky PTV
Prolia play a player
right let me channel my inner a sa now
this last game dang I had the perfect
like team layout to survive that I
should have just kept going I was really
planning on going alright neo boys got
the got the jump controls you know peace
out black olives oh no all right it's
gonna be a quick game I'm gonna try my
best
I've never been great at train yard and
there's something gold here
I got it oh crap
wait hold on what what what he is
lagging oh man maybe I should have
stopped them like healed that little bit
of my shield left oh man oh I'm
accidentally pinging it I forgot to go
to next teammate is square not X my bad
oh the train stopped here to take my
shield unless you didn't kill her I
don't think he killed her
and Artemi is leaving our other team a
behind now you've got me back for you
get my bad crap they see in there all
right underneath you
oh my goodness he doesn't see him is the
axe headphones on their feet are pretty
loud no I guess not
he doesn't know where they are
all right well from Romania nice let's
go team a oh no someone's flying in apex
when your favorite games noise is
definitely not on my list I have a lot
of fun although we're gonna eat it right
now
he's executing stop healing and shooter
oh my goodness he just watched you get
executed he watched that death right
there oh no someone else is flying in oh
boy it's a party watching me play
awesome nice gameplay oh geez I have not
been playing all that well
but it's all good it's actually been a
while but it feels good to play apex
again she doesn't see see oh my god this
about to be such a spicy drop right now
holy moly holy moly holy moly there
and I go tried to go to where my box was
but that lifeline took my shield and she
was like I am out of here
no sorry Abed Tisa it's okay there's
nothing get in there anyways my old box
I'll keep what I have in here no just an
anvil freakin ammo
I need energy level same
I'm sure going on oh man all right I
don't know where those people in but go
here gosh I'm so low on ammo
I'll give you behind you go radio
totally out of ammo oh my goodness I'm
just I'm useless that's that's the deal
here
[Music]
we get it beautiful
but we ain't got no energy animal
[Music]
no oh man goodbye world goodbye world oh
we're so far wait wait oh you better res
now we've got it
Reds dude oh my gosh oh my goodness
why did we stick around it's all good
it'd be like that sometimes I could like
I was a havoc and I'm really bad with
that gun so at least there's that
oh I teammates still here he's about to
die of the Ring goodbye nice knowing you
oh my goodness
all right I tried I did a little bit of
damage there all again I'd rather leave
off like that than the one before
all right so we chillin any whom the
Bloodhound event super fun all the skins
and everything like dope and that little
area from earlier was really really fun
did not even realize that that could be
done
I had only really seen it like way in
the beginning and the trailers when I
hadn't seen people doing it so I'm
excited I got to try it
anywho thank you guys for tuning in
don't forget that every single weekday
at 2:00 p.m. Pacific time we are alive
and you can hang out with us play some
games and just chill out that's that's
all what this dream is for I said she'll
play games have a good time and yeah
so I hope you guys enjoyed it and I hope
you're staying safe out there and I hope
that you're doing well please come back
next time and hang out with us again see
you later
[Music]
you
you